Ausgerechnet deutsche unternehmen planen eine weitere spektakuläre mondlandung das projekt mission to the moon eines berliner
Startups wird beispielsweise von audi und vodafone unterstützt und schon im kommenden jahr soll das erste privat finanzierte
Und unbemannte raumschiff nach 384 1400 kilometern reise auf den mond aufsetzen
zwei rover sollen dann den
landeplatz der apollo 17 mission
Besuchen wie sehen die pläne konkret aus und wie realistisch ist das ganz herzlich willkommen zum science fiction
Ein
verrücktes projekt
So ein projekt leiter von audi über die mission to the moon ursprünglich hatten sechs ingenieure und wissenschaftler im jahr
2007 die idee die erste private mond mission ins leben zu rufen sie gründeten, ein. Unternehmen namens petit sein dass das mittlerweile
46 mitarbeiter beschäftigt der krasse plan. Eine falcon 9 rakete soll schon 2009 10 von cape canaveral in florida
Auf in richtung mond starten und die verantwortlichen der mission to the moon backen keineswegs
Kleine brötchen vergleichen das ganze projekt mit dem apollo-programm an dem über jahre hinweg knapp
40.000 menschen getötet hatten der fahrzeughersteller audi ist im jahr 2014 in die mission, eingestiegen. Und zuständig für die technische
Unterstützung und die kommunikation über das ganze projekt beispielsweise war das unternehmen an der energieversorgung und dem antrieb beteiligt
Und hat zudem dazu beigetragen den rover leichter. Zu machen sein name audi
Luna quattro der mittlerweile sind noch 30 kilogramm wiegt dazu
Ein sprecher für uns als audi ist sehr stand das thema raumfahrt
Einzusteigen raumfahrt ist das thema des 21. Jahrhunderts. Und jetzt noch, ein
Paar details zum rover sein motor läuft auf solar basis das heißt die energie wird aus der sonneneinstrahlung gewonnen die räder der
Leichtbaukonstruktion bestehen aus aluminiumlegierung werden per 3d druck hergestellt getestet
wurden sie in einem becken im vulkanland
Er hat allradantrieb und soll mit der landefähre alina tatsächlich über lte
Mobilfunk, kommunizieren dafür sitzt dem wunder von tochter bell labs mit im boot. Und
vodafone plant ernsthaft ein
lte-netz auf dem mond aufzubauen
und somit eine kommunikationsinfrastruktur für kommende
mondmissionen anderer unternehmen zu errichten klingt verdammt nach einer großen marketing geschichte aber das bestreiten die beteiligten unternehmen, und
forschungsteams hartnäckig demnach seien die
Apollo-missionen nichts anderes als pr gewesen und es sei lediglich darum gegangen flaggen in den mondboden
Zusammen heißt es in interviews ja man habe natürlich schon, gewisse erwartungen an das projekt das am ende auch. Nützliche ergebnisse
und inspirationen liefern
So heißt es von offizieller seite inhaltlich sondern es dabei vor allem darum gehen das lunar rover
Michael, lrv. Von apollo 17
Das seit 50. Jahren dort oben steht wissenschaftlich. Zu untersuchen was ist seitdem mit
Ihm passiert gibt es mittlerweile staub auf dem fahrzeug und sind die gurte bereits verrottet oder noch als solche
Zu erkennen fragen über fragen auf die die mission to the moon seriöse antworten
Geben, will natürlich in live bildern die red bull nur. Um nochmal eine marke zu droppen direkt zur erde übertragen wird
und na klar ist an dieser stelle ganz klar festzuhalten
dass den
Verantwortlichen natürlich sehr an einer weltweiten medienpräsenz gelegen ist und selbst wenn die mission scheitern sollte ist
ihr eine gewisse aufmerksamkeit natürlich
nicht zu verleugnen zurück zum
Inhaltlichen insgesamt sind drei missionen geplant die seien bereits fix gemacht alle fracht plätze an bord von lande fairen und rover bereits
Verkauft der käufer der gesamten dritten mission ist tatsächlich die europäische weltraumagentur esa auf mehr als 200 millionen euro belaufen. Sich die
Kosten dafür das ziel der dritten mission ist übrigens der südpol des mondes. Wo der rover
ein
Liter wasser gewinnen soll das dort vermutlich gefroren vorkommt auch hier betonen die verantwortlichen die große
wissenschaftliche bedeutung zudem habe das ganze projekt auch eine botschaft an alle
leute da draußen zitat du kannst in den weltraum fliegen
Und du kannst dein leben damit bestreiten bevor die mission to the moon dann tatsächlich
Auch startet gibt es allerdings oft zu tun die endmontage steht noch aus und auch an der flugabwehr wird
Noch intensiv gearbeitet zudem sollen vor dem start. Noch analog test durchgeführt werden, ähnlich wie beim
Apollo programm als die nasa. Komplette mission auf war bei durchgespielt. Hat denn die bedingungen auf dem mond sind nicht
Ohne seinen boden ist 120 grad. Heiß und die sonne strahlt erbarmungslos herab die
umgebungstemperatur des weltraums liegt bei minus
270 grad celsius das müssen die batterien des
luna quattro
Erst einmal aushalten es wird sich also in der nächsten zeit schon zeigen wie ernst man die mission wirklich nehmen kann, denn
Er ist alle auch
Einen musk arbeitet mit druck am selben ziel ja wenn
Ihr kein video verpassen wollt denn das passiert wenn
Ihr euch auf die abo box von youtube verlasst dann sollte, er, ihr mich bei den messenger. Whatsapp
Und so weiter ändern das ganze geht gleich hier dann werdet
Ihr von mir vor allen anderen über die neuesten videos informiert täglich und garantiert außerdem solltet
ihr unbedingt meinem schwesterkanal
folgen
Clixoom social and media und wenn, er ihn abonniert das geht auch. Hier unbedingt nicht vergessen die
Genau, die glocke der vater täglich neues aus der social media welt und ansonsten würde ich
Euch noch dieses video empfehlen da geht es. Auch. Um mondmissionen ansonsten bis. Dann
bleibt dran